you know all the things they would say
about trump it's like the big problem is
listen man to all the trump haters i'm
like i hear you i'm a lot of it but bro
when you come to me like i would sit
down with someone like why do you
dislike trump
seven out of the ten things they said
were fake news
did you see what happened with shinzo
abe when he's like just dumping he's
making us look bad i'm like oh you mean
when he did what shinzo did first like
shinzo dumped the food in so trump said
okay and then followed suit you're
blaming him for that well he's meeting
with with dictators and i'm like
negotiating peace deals with dictators
is a bad thing now obama did it
with the casters
which i didn't care for i'm not saying
that's necessarily good but the idea is
that this is unprecedented we've never
seen this before in the history like
what
always negotiate first i mean you can
the very fine people betray your allies
the worst case scenario you know the
very fine people hoax joe biden used to
launch his campaign yeah a lie i did for
2017 i did a database of all the bogus
and sloppy and just flat-out false
reporting of the trump administration
and it ended up being about a 13-page
document if you printed out and i
stopped after 2017 because it was too
much work
there was so much nonsense to the point
and even now people are continuing some
of it i drawing a blank on his name
he's a presidential historian who works
for nbc is still railing against melania
trump's uh renovation of the rose garden
talking about how she made it into some
weird sort of fascist icon or she just
returned it to the 1962 kennedy
blueprint and he's like he's she's
destroyed what jacqueline kind of
remember when cnn reported that trump's
salt and pepper shaker was larger than
everyone else's how were these stories
and it wasn't even necessarily trump's
pepper shaker it was like in front of
him to the right was like two larger
square shakers and then to his left was
like smaller ones and they're like look
it's bigger it's like i'm sure
everyone's you trump doesn't have like
his own he pulls out of his coat he's
like it's fine i remember once looking
up and cnn had a chiron and it said
trump gets two scoops of ice yes and i
was like go turn cartoons on literally
anything else what am i to be fair
though that woman does these
no she her whole gag is that she does
goofy funny recording story but the
problem is that all of cnn started to
look like all of her no no no they all
of cnn picked up the story and then i
ended up seeing i can't i don't know
which show it was but they were like two
scoops of ice cream and then they ran
the story
i'm willing to bet jeff sucker was like
hey that actually plays well can you
re-roll it like in the next show you
know you know what jeff sucker he was he
was uh he is he out at cnn he's still
there right he's still there do you know
so for those that aren't familiar he's
the president i believe right president
of cnn yes oh i'm getting hazing as
chief something or other of it what was
his job before cnn nbc and what did he
produce at nbc apprentice
that's which is a donald trump uh
journalism
i've written about this jeff zucker's
stewardship of cnn has turned cnn cnn
has wwe e-ified the news it's all about
heels and faces you got the good guys
and the bad guys and tonight don lemon
is going to take on parents who love
their children and don't want him to be
masked like last night he was like just
because you have kids doesn't mean you
should have them yeah i said it like
this isn't new what just because you
have kids he was yeah i'm not making
this up by the way he was like railing
again he should take your kids from you
he was railing against parents who were
anti-having their kids masked for eight
hours a day in school and his big the
big line that people immediate wrote
about and stuff was just because you
have kids doesn't mean you should
period yeah i said it wow like what this
isn't even analysis you just
i can't even say the word you're just
what is this this is this is like w e f
w
that's not fair though to wwe because
wwe is over the top fun
also as i've written before wwe also has
the courage to admit what it is and
doesn't pretend to be anything else but
when i watch this clip recently i don't
know when it's from i don't watch watch
it but it was john cena's birthday or
something and he you know this clip he
like walks out and everyone's like
pointing and he's like he looks over
there's a present and he opens it and
it's a folding chair
like it's funny it's funny
it's also fake
yeah right but that's the thing that we
is fake yeah
hold on it's supposed to be i don't i
don't like the word fake when talking
about wrestling because it's
entertaining it's fiction
cnn is not supposed to be fiction right
but that's the thing they have the same
approach which is heels and faces
there's a good guy and see since donald
trump left office their ratings have
tanked it's been across the board people
don't know what to talk about that's why
you find the next they've been focusing
on tucker carlson and fox news the fox
news has to be the new trump because
trump's right office well they've tried
i love it uh brian stelter is like what
what what who he keeps trying to pin it
on someone else is is tucker carlson the
new trump yeah and then who else did he
accuse is uh
they went after marjorie taylor green it
didn't stick they took carlson it
doesn't stick yeah they found a new
person who seems like everybody they try
to accuse someone else of being the new
trump because they're they are desperate
to find a trump right there's only one
stone called steve austin though yeah so
you just can't replace him and that's
you see this in the news you see this in
msnbc honestly
if you told me in 2016 that msnbc would
be the slightly more reputable network
than cnn during the trump era i would
have said you're crazy
but i have to say it msnbc actually was
more reputable for all those years oh i
mean but all this kind of seems almost
beside the point but this goes to we
have the president who we have now
because people were told they needed to
be terrified of the other guy because
the stuff he did was dangerous and going
to get everyone killed and the irony now
is we're looking at a situation where a
lot of people god forbid you know just
keep praying that doesn't happen in
afghanistan
and this is what we're at and i i find
myself look i don't blame biden voters
there is a part of me though that is
largely angry because biden is such a
known entity if you did not know this is
who he is that's on you you had 40 years
of material to look over there there's a
a few ways i approach this so so for one
you know i talked about the other day
that when it comes to fascist policies i
blame those who uphold them so with like
the new york city mandates who's making
the mandate and who's enforcing it it's
the mom and pop shops that are enforcing
it because the cops can't go to every
single restaurant no it's only because
the citizens of new york are willing to
do it uh who who's who's the one who's
confiscating people's weapons and their
right to keeping their arms the police
who are doing it
however
with the american voter
i don't necessarily blame every person
who voted for biden for for biden now
it's true that if you voted for biden
you voted for this but the media
who is manipulating and lying and and
ripping off the american people deserve
a massive amount of the blame for this
at the end of the day i think it's the
responsibility of the individual to be
informed and if you're just watching cnn
and believing it without doing any fact
checking yeah you bear responsibility
but how do you deal with cnn msnbc and
their outright lies over and over again
look man never been a big fan of fox
news not a big fan of a lot of their
hosts but they're news
i like chris wallace i think he's
straight he's straight with the news
and cnn is is anything but it's hard to
find you know i i i have this thing on
my instagram from a couple years ago
i call it the i think we call it the cnn
challenge and what you do is you turn on
you turn on uh fox news and uh and then
see what they're reporting and then see
turn and then switch to cnn and see if
they're reporting on substantive world
news
and so the the challenge is when you put
on cnn what are or you put on fox news
what would i get so i'm like oh there's
protests in iran uh a week later it's
it's a hurricane a large storm is coming
to the u.s you know
be prepared get supplies and i'm like
okay let's see what's on cnn and what
was it a panel talking about trump every
single time and project veritas did had
that expose where you had a guy who said
we don't we don't report anymore
cnn used to go out and go on the ground
now it's like we all just sit around
because they're doing trump panels all
day i should say i should clarify that a
lot of my criticism is for cnn's
primetime
u.s news reporting there are a lot of
people on the digital side who do a lot
of great reporting especially especially
international porn and cnn international
itself is almost like its own entity
yeah completely devoid of zucker's over
oversight but you turn on like anything
between noon to 10 p.m and it's just
it's again it's like watching
professional wrestling but with suits
and ties you might as well just be
watching like a video of chickens
clucking it's like you're gonna be an
insult to chickens at least they're
doing good honest work that's true it's
true you know they're feeding families
that's true but i just mean to say that
you're not going to get any information
no in fact i'm sorry i'm sorry that's
wrong because if you watch chickens
clucking you'll you'll understand
chicken clocks after certain time be
like wow that the rooster did that call
that must mean danger you turn on cnn
you get dumber
you get less informed you get
misinformed and then they blame everyone
else for their problems
now you end up with people who live in
this matrix dimension
the problem look i don't mind the press
that's opinionated i've long time said
the idea of an impartial press is kind
of a bs idea
really sort of popularized in like the
early 19th century the idea that you
know you use minimal words and all that
is a lot of it's about saving ink and
paper
i don't mind if you have an opinion or
slant just be honest with me and if you
have a slant or an opinion just be fair
in your coverage if look if we had a
press being as tough and as
uncompromising on joe biden things might
have gone differently i'm not saying he
would have lost him we had collusion
between big tech and the media to shut
down news stories that made that made
hunter biden and joe biden look bad not
just that but you also had the president
would disappear for days on end in his
basement and people were like oh well
he's probably having some ice cream now
what did donald trump say today i'm like
whoa hold on as it turns out apparently
having a president whose entire campaign
strategy was to hide in his basement
wasn't great because they were seeing it
now in real time that's why i say trump
was anti-elected people when they when
when people hit that biden button or or
box they weren't saying biden they were
saying no trump right
spite vote is such a powerful thing look
president former president barack obama
was a very exciting very likable very
charismatic candidate in his own right
but also a spite vote in 2008 was addre
who was a direct answer to george w was
so unpopular at the time people weren't
necessarily voting against john mccain
they were voting against george w bush
who they were very unhappy with and it
helped that the democratic candidate was
extremely select and extremely easy to
want to vote for oh i mean i wasn't
covering politics at the time but even i
just casually watching the news knew
obama was going to win like you watch
that guy and be like yeah no i he's
going to be the next president oh yeah
yeah and then 2012.
no 2012 mitt romney
mitt romney is such a difficult person
because he's such i think he's a decent
man a good man and a seasoned and
successful executive
but he always carried himself like he
was embarrassed to be a republican like
he's always kind of apologized he still
is why
just i mean this is it's funny because
donald trump did to the nth degree what
i was screaming during 2012 was like own
it you're rich you're successful own it
and then donald trump was like okay okay
maybe
don't own it so hard because mitt romney
cares more about the opinion of the new
york times than he does about the
american people there's so many
republicans like that and they're
interested they'll never like you why do
you do this they will never appreciate
you you're always going to be that that
weird kid on the playground that amuses
them but you're never going to be in the
clique yeah they will be like hey bite
this bite this worm in
it's half gross no no get out of here
get out of here weirdo yeah it was you
see this with uh cable news and and even
newspapers the the hallowed former gop
strategist who hasn't been a republican
or done anything conservative for the
last 30 years but they're trotted out to
say something bad about republican
because because you know what blue on
red that's expected but red unread
violence ooh dramatic this is great
bring out nicole wallace or john uh
steve schmidt steve schmidt oh adam
kensinger a republican said
come on does anybody really
does
what they're doing with these like with
bill crystal and these neocons who are
now all of a sudden cheerleaders of the
democratic party jennifer rubin is one
of the one of the best right
she she starts
she she's the kind of conservative quote
unquote who comes out in his life and
says like i'm a principled conservative
and trump is bad and the democrats cheer
for it and then when trump when it comes
to like stacey abrams she's cheering for
stacey abrams then you get the lincoln
project they're like we got to restore
the party of lincoln so we're anti-trump
then trump you know gets voted out and
they go
well trump-ism is still the republican
party so where were the democrats i
guess yeah now you have them going on
being like well we're going to have to
save gavin newsom in california i'm like
what part of this is conservative steve
schmidt is marched out to this day on
msnbc regularly in the chiron it says
former gop strategist and he comes out
he's like the republican party there's
now the party of fascism
former gop strategist he hasn't done
anything successful since arnold
schwarzenegger was re-elected in 2006.
he's dining out on that credit for
almost as long as we've been in
afghanistan and yet they just pump them
out because this is this is what they
want these are the republicans that who
are republicans i i would not put mitt
romney in the same category with steve
schmidt but there's there's that weird
strain of like embarrassed like i know
my rank and file are loud and they wear
red hats and i'm sorry i'm sorry people
say rhino republican and name only oh i
remember that one people said
absolutely all the time but you know who
the real rhinos are it's like thomas
massey and rand paul because they're the
odd people out the entirety of the
republican party is around doing nothing
and then you get a small handful of
people who actually stand up and if i
gotta if i'm gonna look at the majority
of the republican party as you know
on their best day of speed bump for
democrats and then i look at you know
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert uh
rand paul thomas massey who actually
stand up for stuff and holly and a few
others
i'm like they're
they're not the same as the republicans
i mean arizona democratic senator uh
christian cinema is more reliable for
what i want and she's the democrat oh
and joe manchin i'm like they're
actually more aligned with me than a lot
of these other supposed celebrity
republicans who get trotted out on cable
news to go trump is bad tucker
tucker called lindsey graham a leftist
oh lindsey graham
i mean right i don't i don't think i
have his harsher criticism when you were
saying rand paul was a rhino i was like
i think he would not want to be called
republican i think he still prefers
libertarian but he's in the republican
party so right i mean he's not
he's not his father i'll just leave it
the republican party
is the the group of weirdos in high
school who wish they were in with the
popular kids
and the democrats are like obama is a
celebrity you know he's a rock star they
got the media
they love it republican the republicans
are suit wearing stodgy and unhip and
they're not with it so you get all these
republicans who are desperate to make
the new york times happy because they
want to be cool but they'll never be
cool nobody likes being hated but it
just kind of blows my mind that a lot of
these republicans forget yeah like 50 of
the country if not more behind you
you don't have to win over that other
half that despises you not for long
don't well we'll see about that
this you know i always come back to this
the idea that i know it's always going
to slip away and we just can't win and
all that stuff i like and maybe it's too
simplistic but if you can't sell and
package liberty to voters then maybe
you're just a bad salesman maybe the
problem is you we need better we i'm a
conservative i'm not a republican i
haven't been a registered republican for
a long time
uh conservatives need better
spokespeople
spokesmen and women let me be exact
about it and the idea that no it's just
not going to work we can't we can't win
we can't sell liberty why can't we sell
liberty they can certainly sell big
government how can we not package
something that's far more attractive
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time